yeah I know when to welcome to this
video link wjw from the netherlands i
guess the englisha with III and in
charge against it had before is quite
dangerous okay yeah so TM e 392 probably
difficult like to get the five-year
going you can do ask yourself how it's
going to develop itself is queenside
easily him I wonder Bishop a three and
potentially 90 form a three is not easy
let's see 94 I'm not sure that is the
threat relevant might be okay but he has
to take with the rupiah which is pretty
dreadful now I've got nice pressure now
against t6d five I can take a seventh
winning material
maybe no I was thinking maybe for which
that's not going to be working either
i'm outside or something i wonder if
nick has to do something he can cannot
just sit on all the weaknesses i def
time okay so my idea is to go right xbox
don't go to the night to d 5 194 well 95
I know it looks good but it isn't
threaten all that much yeah this is
there a lot of nice continuations have
even just taking on d5 is just a nice
flight taking on 35 the 95
[Music]
I want to get clarify the structure
and it's mostly because there are many
good-looking continuations and now this
is more tempting as 97 as a threat now
that looks pretty awful
so giving and giving the exchange and
this is winning the exchange no real not
to do it maybe four okay before maybe
was an option ok so here I think okay
until four no this first and then deform
don't want to give up fee for them now
we form a success sorry a b7 is under
fire by the bishop and the night doesn't
have a good square to go 986 I take be
797 gap probably also just take it okay
seven is also a Google well I guess this
one
if i take it queen b 6i can take e 60 k
[Music]
jha very little compensation here
[Music]
this will be T 6 and then 25 something
like that yeah d 6 that also covers look
so everything is covered it's a good way
to convert making sure that all the
pieces have good coordination yet black
resign and when opening result was
pretty dreadful it's um it's no let me
five is not such a good idea here before
it's just very awkward I mean Blackstone
as a playable position but you have to
do this extends its that's basically the
only move taking is giving giving why
too much if he grabs this we get a
fantastic position with white and then
like that is pretty dreadful and TN I
mean vices just the turbocharged screen
side initiative there that the drilling
service is pretty pretty pretty tough
for black you just just hard to play I
think you had to play you for it some
more resistor just to make life more
yeah more difficult for me in somewhere
like here yeah yeah there should be six
lucozade is not a move to love to play
with your probably action here I was
thinking maybe the default just to
confuse me but I can take here i am that
that's true as yet another another fork
name is explaining politely
now that was essentially decided in the
opening luck has to play I mean if I've
is already a bit questionable but if you
if you play it then you have to go t6
now and this is still mean it's nice
that white is gotten before and so
easily but it's not something the size
of yet ok guys thanks for watching